but I have everybody's attention please
before the results are declared and I
would just like to express my sincere
thanks to the whole team that has
supported the election process a huge I
[Applause]
think a huge amount of effort has gone
into the process over the past six weeks
not just over the past 24 hours I think
special praise must be extended to of my
deputy and the elections team who have
really pulled out all the stops to
ensure a smooth running of the election
process this evening and I hope you
would agree
so I Wallace Sampson being the acting
returning officer at the election for
the Member of Parliament for the
Harrogate and nez bred constituency on
Thursday the 8th of June 2017 do hereby
give notice that the number of Oz
recorded for each candidate at the state
election is as follows Flynn Helen
Katherine Liberal Democrats 13,000 309
[Music]
Fraser
Donnell George independent 559 Jones
Andrew Hansen the Conservative Party
candidate 31,000 477
[Applause]
see words Mark James Labour Party eleven
thousand three hundred and ninety five
[Applause]
they will total of 139 spoil ballot
papers and turn out to seventy four
percent and I do hereby declare that
Jones Andrew Hansen is duly elected
[Applause]
well good evening ladies and gentlemen
that this election has been overshadowed
by the terrible terrorist attacks that
we have seen in Manchester and London
and in the face of such such awful
incidents people across the country have
come together to show support for the
victims and their families I think that
has demonstrated the best of British
people from our community have been
involved and that has brought home the
horror and our thoughts are with them
now this has been an election of some
surprises and I think it will require
much analysis it has certainly been very
hard to predict but I'm deeply honored
to have the trust placed in me once
again by the people of this area it is a
great honor to represent your home area
at the highest possible level and I will
work to repay that trust I will work to
build upon the progress that we have
made over the past few years to work to
improve the connectivity of our area to
maintain the strength of our economy and
to make our area one of the most
friendly in the country for people
suffering suffering from dementia now of
course we'll be facing some huge
decisions over the next few years on a
national basis I will make sure that the
voice of Harrogate knaresborough and
borough bridge is heard loud and clear
during that process I'd like to finish
with some things I'd like to thank the
returning officer and all the team at
the council the elections team and the
counting officers that these elections
here run very smoothly and I know from
experience just what a good team they
are I'd like to also thank the police
for their work in keeping us safe and to
my campaign team as a whole for all of
their work but within that I would like
to thank Richard Cooper for his local
leadership Don McKenzie for his
campaigning zeal and organisation and
agent Sam Gibbs for making it all happen
but my main thanks of course are to the
people of Harrogate to Knaresborough to
our community for their trust in me it
is humbling to have it and I will